what's going on everyone my name's alex
from ozzie and i am the host of the show
owner of allen prestige labs gym launch
120 million in sales
um in 44 45 months um
and i have nothing to sell you so what i
want to talk about today
is something that i think is really
important i get a lot of questions about
and it's about long-term short-term
investing some big pitfalls and i just
want to share with you some of the
mistakes that i've made
in this kind of transition that i've
been through going from kind of ceo to
kind of investor slash capital allocator
right so the first thing is i want to
share some some some stats with you that
i found really interesting
i think it was fidelity uh did a study
it was either fidelity or charles schwab
did a study on which investor profiles
and activity
yielded the best returns uh in terms of
total portfolio value
right and this was in stocks and they
found that there were two categories
far outpaced everyone else
let me tell you what they were the first
and highest performing
uh portfolio activity were people who
had
purchased stocks and then died
and so as a result there was no more
activity in their account
and their accounts outperformed everyone
else
the second highest were people who
purchased
uh accounts or purchased stocks for the
account and then had forgotten their
password
as a result had not done any trading and
so for me
i think this is hilarious because it
shows credible flaws in human judgment
and it also shows the power of
compounding growth when buying
businesses in general
because then you just get exposure
because if you think about this from
across
all of the accounts that they have then
across all of the accounts then they
have equal exposure to ups and downs etc
so across all of those accounts which is
just like taking an index of the market
the people who do the least amount have
the most money
in the account now what i want to do is
explain to you a mistake that
uh i made probably like two weeks ago uh
that cost me
shoot i have to do the math it probably
cost me 200 grit yeah it tossed me 200
grand
all right so here's a 200 000 mistake
that you don't have to make i'm gonna
walk you through the math
all right so what i was doing um is i
have
in my quote portfolio i guess it's not a
quote portfolio it's my portfolio
um i have three to five percent of it uh
in investable assets that i candidly i
just play around with
and it scratches my entrepreneurial itch
and
just me being a human being 95 it's
actually 97
of my uh worth is in really really
stable stuff all right
but i want to talk to you about the five
percent so
here's the difference between holding
versus trading
all right and this is something that is
massively underlooked
and i'm hoping to at least convince one
person who's listening to this
that if you look at the math you you see
how quickly
you shouldn't do you shouldn't try and
you shouldn't try and beat the market
um by by by trading all right
and so here's here's the first reality
is that there's huge quantitative firms
that have
hundreds of analysts who are trying to
beat you and they they make their money
doing that
um but the second one is a simple
hundred dollar example all right
so let's say you have a hundred dollars
all right
so this is our this is our initial
capital all right i'm going to give you
two scenarios that we're going to walk
through
so in scenario number one we're going to
have our
day trading example and let's say that
over x period of time
you do really well now i'm just going to
ignore the fact that
most people are just going to lose money
all right so that's that's probably like
75 of all of us are going to mess up
somehow and think we're going to beat it
you know i'm going to quote by the dip
and then it just goes down by another 50
right but let's just assume you double
your money
all right so your 100 becomes 200
all right everyone's cool so let's just
say that happens over a five year
timeline
whatever all right now the point here
is that uh it doesn't really matter
because if you're in this
as soon as you are doing this through
trading
then the capital gains treatment gets
thrown out the window and it becomes
regular income all right so you're taxed
differently
so this hundred dollar gain right that
you have here
from 100 to 200 gets taxed
at uh 45 you know 43 whatever it
is and so you have a uh an additional
let's see here so that means that after
this whole period of time you're gonna
you're gonna be
left with a hundred and
uh forty [ __ ] sorry 155 dollars
all right sorry about that 155 which are
left after tax all right
post tax now don't worry i'm going to
show you a third scenario in a second
the second scenario is you do it and you
instead of trading that whole time
you just earn the same amount 200
100 turns to 200 and candidly the
my all my passive stuff is out has
outperformed my active stuff which is
hilarious but uh which just confirms
this for me which is why i'm making this
video
all right so let's just say that you
still you make the same hundred dollars
all right we're good there
hundred dollars but now it's capital
gains all right so instead of being left
with 155 dollars we're now left with a
hundred and eighty dollars
wow well that's bigger but let me show
you
and this is the thing that kind of blew
my mind um because that's why i love
looking at the math so much
is well then how much would i have to
gain from day trading or trading on
shorter terms or swing trades or
whatever
um for this to be worth it right
how how much extra money would i have to
make
to outpace the fact that i'm i'm getting
this
regular income tax treatment on my
income
all right so here's what's crazy so
in order for me to get to net eighty
dollars right
i would have to take that hundred dollar
investment and turn it into
i did the math earlier it's um uh 245
dollars
all right so that means that i would
have to
my growth here would have to be 50 you
know 45 percent higher
right isn't that crazy in order to yield
because that times the regular tax
treatment gets me 180
all right so if i'm comparing the two
things if i want to be left with 180
option one is i buy something and i
forget about it and then
later if i you know five years later i'm
i sell it for whatever reason
and i am left with 180 because i only
had to pay capital gains on it
in scenario in order for me to to just
match that not even beat it
i would have to take my hundred dollars
and turn it into 245 dollars
and then sell it and this is obviously
this whole time you're continuing to
flip things and buy things and buy
things right
and then after the regular income tax
i'd be left with
180 all right and so when i saw that
illustration
it became so obvious to me because i had
had some decent gains in something
um and so i decided to sell it and
i actually ended up selling it at a good
time uh because it ended up going down
because i felt like it was getting
overvalued
um and so i thought i felt pretty good
about myself
right and
what ended up happening is uh the thing
ended up
coming back up to exactly where i had
sold it
again and so if i had literally just
done nothing
then i would have more money because now
i have to pay
i have to pay taxes on regular income
because i sold it within a year
and mind you again guys this is on my
three to five percent i don't touch
anything that's
that's not that all right so i'm just
being very clear and candid here
nor do i recommend you do that so if you
need the look if you need the itch
then i would say put your put three
percent aside
um for pure speculation which is just
like i'm which is basically just saying
i'm a human being and
i'm an idiot and this is how i can
manage my idiocy
um but but when you see the math spelled
out like this
between this is what smart people do and
this is what
dumb people who don't make as much money
do then it makes me so much more
inclined
to just do what smart people do and take
all of that extra time and just do
something else or just make money with
my extra time
um one of my good friends he uh
i've known him for 20 25 years
and when i met him he was i think he was
he was managing
i mean maybe five million dollars like
not which in the finance world is not a
lot for management
um and now 25 years later
i think he manages 3.5 billion he's one
of the most stable people that i know
and when i talk to him about this stuff
he's like you need a hobby
and so i guess the message that i have
for everyone is maybe get a hobby
and just let the money grow and pretend
you're a dead person
and if you can't pretend you're a dead
person then throw away your password
uh or give it to somebody that you would
be ashamed to ask for your password back
uh so that you just don't touch your
stuff because
ultimately you'll probably be you'll
probably end up getting higher gains
a and b you'll get taxed less on those
gains so i hope that was valuable for
you i hope this makes sense i hope you
get a laugh out of my
200 000 mistake that i just made in the
last two weeks
um keep being awesome lots of love like
subscribe and leave a comment and i'll
try and
get back to everybody who does so
keeping awesome kitchen bye